and then yesterday the Labour leader
Jeremy Corbyn raised some eyebrows by
attending an anti Trident rally while
his party held a day of campaigning
about Europe its added fuel to the
suggestion among some that the Labour
leadership heart isn't really in the
campaign I'm joined now by the Labour MP
Cho got a mother he was the shadow
business secretary remember until
September and is now member of the Home
Affairs Select Committee supporting the
Britain stronger in Europe campaign to
make that clear and a very good morning
to you and learning them get that sense
you know this is an analysis from some
of your colleagues in the party that mr.
Corbett's heart isn't really in it and
there he was highlighting I suppose
Labour's divisions over trying when you
should have been highlighting the
Conservatives divisions over Europe well
I think on tridon there's a range of
views in the labour party on one way I
have to declare an interest I'm a member
of both the GMB and unite unions they've
been very clear that we must maintain
the deterrent for me it's a national
security issue I think it goes beyond
party politics and I will do what I
think is the best thing in my own
constituents interest and that's how I
think people treat us and in the end
what unites us is I think everybody
whether you want to maintain the
deterrent or not wants a nuclear future
a nuclear free future the question is
how do we get there that's where the
disagreement is on Europe I actually
spoke to Jeremy this week at a
conversation with him about Europe this
weekend it's heart absolutely is in
keeping us in the European Union he's an
internationalist he wants to see greater
prominence given to the dimension of
year of the social Europe dimension
which helps protects people's rights at
work and ensures we've built a fairer
more equal and more sustainable world
he's very clear that you can only do
that say for example when we look at the
unfolding environmental catastrophe
which knows no borders we can only do
that by working on a supranational level
but I mean there's been other people
talking about Europe today the yeah well
yeah yeah yeah but we'll get on to it in
a moment but you know the idea that
jeremy corbyn's heart isn't really in it
it was just that contrast you know of
something weak which he cares
passionately about you describing
Labour's internal divisions on trident
and the nuclear issue but if he really
does
feel passionately as you do about
britain remaining in the European Union
people say well should roll his sleeves
up even be a bit more like the Prime
Minister the Prime Minister's been
tweeting that he's talked to 4,000
people in the last week about his the
England should remember Korman hasn't
done that I'm not I'm not sure I'd want
Jeremy hoping to be like our prime
minister but he will be more active and
he's already doing that by trying to get
the labour party taking more of a
leadership role with our other sister
parties in Europe for promoting that
social Europe dimension of what the
European Union brings and the idea that
somehow the European Union is some
Merkel inspired project is nonsense
we've got center-left and socialist
governments in Italy Matteo Renzi Venice
Renzi's doing a great job in Italy we've
got the Swedish Social Democrats of
course we've got front of our London in
Paris and in France the idea that
somehow the EU is some neoliberal
construct is a load of garbage hmm hey
you wanted to get on to what we've been
hearing from Ian Duncan Smith this
morning obviously a prominent campaigner
to leave the European Union ended coming
it's a broad position but you know what
it comes down to is sovereignty and
control and I've just been talking in my
newspaper of you about things like weak
kettles and toasters and that which
illustrates a broader issue the meddling
by the European Union in a ferry that
should have anything to do with them
shouldn't this notion that somehow the
European Union controls our affairs is a
complete load of nonsense and you need
only look at some of the things that Ian
Duncan Smith has been doing himself that
we've been campaigning against for the
last five to six years imposing the
bedroom tax on some of the most
vulnerable people in society cutting
people's benefits changes to ESA working
with the Chancellor point being that he
was allowed maybe that micro inches in
the last Parliament there were 121 acts
of parliament and just four of them were
to implement exclusively EU legislation
a domestic government here as many
people in my constituency will tell you
because they've suffered because of it
and do a whole load of things and
controls our affairs now where we do
pull sovereignty
the European Union where we can achieve
more by working together than on our own
in nine out of ten times we're on the
majority side of the argument we can
usually marshal a majority on the
European Council behind the UK's
position so I do not understand why the
likes of Iain Duncan Smith and others
continually talk down our country talk
down what we've been able to achieve in
the past and talk down what we can
achieve in the future I mean I using all
the EU brings us live amplified I
thought we formally saw it in Labour's
manifesto in last year's election you
know there are things that work even
keen Europeans like yourself about the
European Union and in particular the
issue of immigration I the Prime
Minister to come back from Brussels
which something is pretty with something
that's pretty similar to what was in
your manifesto about restricting
benefits for EU migrants yeah but Jeremy
Corbyn said he was tinkering and that
that was irrelevant well I don't think
that the renegotiation was irrelevant
granted I would have been arguing for us
to stay in notwithstanding the
renegotiation because I do think the
European Union needs reform I don't
think we just want the status quo but I
think your best place to get reform if
you're round the table actually
influencing things not being like say
Norway is where they're part of the EU
free-trade area but have no say over the
rules but on immigration what people
want is a fair immigration system not a
free-for-all and I do believe for
example having people contribute in for
four years before they can take out
benefits from our Social Security system
is something which will weigh with
people and will be attractive this idea
that we have a free-for-all the idea
that when you arrive at Gatwick or
Heathrow you just walk through and it
doesn't matter who you are look whether
you're from the EU or not through from
the EU we have proper border checks
because we're not part of the Schengen
passport-free area so this notion that
somehow anyone can just walk in and out
I'd invite your viewers just to think
when you arrive at an airport you just
walk through and go and get your baggage
without going to any checks of course
you don't and there is another point
here which is those who argue for us to
leave often talk about the Norwegian
model they want us to carry on trading
like Norway oh yeah and I met with the
deputy leader of the Norwegian Labour
Party this week and she was absolutely
clear that actually from her country's
point of view if they were in the
European
Union not only being in the EU
free-trade area that actually have some
influence over them okay they have no
influence over the rule so what is the
model that people like IDs Nigel Farage
and all these other people want are
stoked about the campaign is in a huh
gosh can't win jump intern and just how
passionately you're putting these points
you know from the Britain stronger in
Europe campaign where you are rubbing
shoulders with the prominent
conservative supporters members of the
Conservative Party there are you must
accept this members of your very own
party who would feel at the very least
uncomfortable to be doing that well but
I mean to be frank on both sides of the
argument people are doing that my
Lambeth colleague labor colleague Kate
Hoey is one of the leading voice voices
in the boat leave campaign but what I
would say is look I think that the
British public are fed up with the kind
of Yabu Punch and Judy type of politics
where we just oppose each other for the
sake of opposing each other what would
be the point of me pretending I don't
agree with the Prime Minister that we
should stay in the European Union for
once I think it's nice to see us working
across party lines in the national
interest I think it shows that we
actually will put principled what we
actually write other areas after this
referendum is don't exhaust it well as
it happens if the referendums done and
dusted them I'm absolutely clam clear
now I'd rather not have a conservative
Prime Minister in Downing Street I'd
much rather have a labor occupant of
that post but I think ultimately you
have more authority when you disagree
when you aren't shy of being clear when
you do agree and when there is some
consensus and one of the things like I'm
going to be leading a debate in the
House of Commons on Thursday on the
serous youth violence which is unfolding
in in the city areas in particular in
the UK that isn't a party political
issue my constituents would take a very
dim view if I started trying to score
party political points on that issue
that last year saw the deaths of 17
teenagers in London must be fascinating
talking to you as ever mr. mana thank
you very much here chuka Amanda there